satoru gojo without any doubt
is one of the coolest anime characters
ever created
and yet what makes his character so
intriguing is not his unimaginable power
or his fantastic sense of humor
but the tragic irony that lies beneath
them
who then is satoru gojo what does it
mean to be
the strongest what is actually going on
behind those cold and clear eyes
and why does he have to cover them it's
time to find out
[Music]
rojo is the strongest curse user in
jiu-jitsu kaisen
akutami in taking inspiration from other
shonen stories
combines and expands upon them and
ultimately makes his characters
even more intriguing and fascinating
satoru gojo
is no exception here many traits of his
can
quite easily be traced back to other
popular shonen characters
but in the end he emerges as one of the
most
unique and complex personalities out
there
[Music]
if i had to pick one word to describe
satoru gojo
no doubt it would be strength gojo
is the pinnacle sorcerer of the ju-2
world he is to curses
what sukuna is to sorceress an
unbeatable force of nature that can at
best be hoped to be sealed away
but not actually killed beneath that
cool exterior
and immense power gojo's tragedy of a
character lies in his immeasurable
strength and how it determines
every aspect of his life as well as his
role in the story
being the strongest character he serves
as a signpost to both the audience
and the protagonists what is actually
possible in this world
and how far behind the other characters
actually still
are gojo's fighting style and the
respect and fear that he enjoys from
both friends and foes alike
is something we know from many other
anime netero
in hunter hunter shanks in one piece
shanks in fairy tale
or almighty and boku no hero like all of
them
goku has a very easy going boyish sort
of personality
that is immediately replaced by pure
strength and authority whenever his
patience is tested
he's the sort of character that almost
single-handedly holds the balance in the
worlds
without them chaos would erupt while
personality and look-wise goku could be
considered a cooler and more
entertaining version of kakashi
as a teacher he comes closer to all
might in that he's
not exactly the best at teaching but
still
good and thoughtful enough to grow the
next generation of
the quote-unquote good guys in fact gojo
has
quite a bunch of wonderful if admittedly
unconventional teaching moments
and while these mentor type of
characters usually feel like their best
days are already
over gojo very much seems to be in his
absolute prime when we first meet him in
the story
akutami makes it very clear very early
on
what gojo is actually capable of
building on sharp reflexes and a bright
tactical intellect
his ridiculous amount of cursed energy
and physical strength as well as his
capability to perform a complete domain
expansion
are only the tip of the iceberg gojo has
been blessed not only with
one but two inherited abilities that in
combination
make him more gods than men
the first of these is limitless an
ability that allows gojo to freely
manipulate
space and matter down to an atomic level
this allows him to slow down movement
and decide what can or cannot actually
touch him we can see this explained in
his fight with jogo in the most
hilarious way
[Music]
this ability makes it possible for gojo
to attract
and repulse matter giving him gravity
and anti-gravity attributes
the red and the blue his most
destructive skill however is combining
both of these attributes into hollow
purple which results in the complete
annihilation of any matter caught within
the attack
as if this wasn't scary enough though
gojo
also inherited the six ice an ability
that we honestly still know
very little about we do know however
that it allows him to perceive the world
around him in terms of mass
cursed energy and so on and so forth
making it the
perfect fit for limitless we can see
this ability in action for example
during the kyoto sister school exchange
event during the attack of hanami's
group on the school
not only was he immediately able to
pinpoint everyone's
exact location but he was also able to
easily assess the increase in ug's
cursed energy outputs
the in detail workings of these
abilities are actually incredibly
cleverly crafted
but not related to the main point of
this video so let me know in the
comments if you'd like to learn more
about gojo's limitless and the six eyes
the main takeaway point here is that
gojo has the one thing valued most in
the world of jujutsu
raw unmatched power this allows him to
shape the world around him in whatever
way he pleases
and this is what brings us into the
deeply nested
and layered realm of gojo satoru's
personality
due to his innate strength and claim to
authority gojo understandably is
extremely confident in his abilities to
the point where he believes himself to
be
invincible in relation to the central
moral argument of jujutsu kaisen
what constitutes a good life his view is
quite different from itadores
while itadore thinks that a good life
means enabling others to have
a good death for gojo the answer is
strength in essence when you have
strength you have
agency over the world your own life and
that of
others thus while yuji expresses his
belief in his hero complex
trying to save anyone weaker than him
and caring way too much about others
gojo is very self-centered and as we
will see
has difficulties understanding and
caring for people weaker than him for
instance he motivates megumi by telling
him to become stronger himself and less
reliant on
others
[Music]
and yet despite their polar views on
life surprisingly
in the end gojo and itadori have one of
the best relationships in the show
on the surface this seems to be due to
their similarly extroverted and
genuinely funny personalities
however both their god and hero complex
keep them from truly creating meaningful
relationships with others
as they can let themselves be vulnerable
by letting anyone come close enough to
help them in return or as gojo
formulates it
yuji and him always go for the home run
in that
sense while expressed in very different
ways both yuji
and gojo share the same fundamental
weakness
loneliness to fully understand gojo's
sense of loneliness we first have to
understand that despite his sense of
superiority
luckily for everyone around him he
actually has also a very strong sense of
morality
gojo cares about the well-being of
humanity and even more so for the people
close to him
however the society of jiu-jitsu
sorcerers in their commitment to
fighting the curses that threaten
humanity and human life
have ironically enough morphed into an
environment that is
incredibly dehumanizing in and of itself
all that matters are bloodlines
influence and
yes strength but despite being blessed
with the most desired trait amongst the
sorcerers
or maybe exactly because of it gojo
knows very well just
how corrupted the society has become his
big desire
and drive therefore is not to eradicate
all curses or something similar
but is pointed inward and aims at
revolutionizing the system of the juju
two world itself
and that's actually a very intriguing
desire for him to have
because it can't be solved by strength
alone
but requires the one thing that gojo
isn't great at
human relationships and comrades with a
common ideology
gojo knows this he doesn't want to be
the strongest forever
in fact he wants to be surpassed however
the main flaw in gojo's thinking is that
he can't help
but resemble the system that he was born
and raised in no matter how hard he
tries to struggle
he's still a part of the system he's
desperately trying to reform and so the
real problem that gojo faces
is that despite his self-centeredness
and his god complex
deep down this man has quite a big heart
and sense of morality that in the end
make him vulnerable hanami and jogo got
away because he prioritized yuji safety
over catching them mahito was able to
steal the cursed objects from the school
because gojo prioritized the lives of
his students
and determined that the true loss would
be their death
and so based on his emotional and
compassionate side
the region gojo feels so incredibly
lonely and isolated is
ironically enough his own strength and
power and i think nothing represents
this better than the key symbolism
of gojo's character his eyes
the reason he wears sunglasses like a
blind man and then
a literal blindfold later on is due to
the fact that he's always staring
into the infinity he always sees
everything this ability is of course
very tiring and the tragedy of it is
that gojo is literally
so good at seeing through people that
they
don't look like individuals to him
anymore every single person on earth is
filled with their own thoughts emotions
and biases
but gojo despite his six eyes doesn't
perceive that he only sees matter cursed
energy
speed and strength gojo has always
distant himself from both his own
feelings and the feelings of others
which then creates a divide between him
and the world around him
thus it's really hard for him to see
other people as
real people this distance to others
shines through in various ways
it's always gojo making the pop cultural
references for instance
[Music]
he was the one who taught ichidori to
literally handle his cursed energy
through his emotions by
literally forcing him to watch movies
and while i strongly believe that
stories are one of the most powerful
tools that we as human beings possess
having feelings due to perceived
strength and usefulness
is not quite the same thing as having
feelings and understanding a person
for who they really are gojole has thus
become a mere observer on the sideline
granted the ability to see everything
life became more of a movie than reality
with gojo being the only one in the
theater or as the master himself would
phrase it
thus gojo literally has to blind himself
and his powers in order to perceive
others as
actual people and i think it's fair to
call that
quite tragic however it also shows us
once again that gojo
really cares he cares that he can't see
people for who they are he cares that he
feels alone
and he cares that people suffer under
the current system
thus gojo willingly dampens his own
powers by blinding himself in order to
see others